[Music]
welcome back to off the record where we
talk about whatever we want and today we
got
alex over here hey guys
hi
how do you guys know each other
and then how did uh we all know each
other i used to he's this guy this guy
used to always come to my classes and he
would be just the only guy in my classes
which classes my kickboxing class i used
to teach thai ball classes my tie bow
kicking
billy blank style shout out to my boy
billy blanks but this guy wouldn't be
the only one in my classes and he would
always linger and he would talk to me
and he was really weird at first but he
i found out he was very nice and he
started hanging out what about him where
you're like i can entrust my
self-defense future to a guy that looks
like him yeah that's true
because when i when i chose a martial
arts coach he wasn't my first pick no
but then after i saw him transition
david and i was like wow
if you could do that for david yeah
it was his lips his lips yeah because
when he would hold mitts for me he'd
always say
because i think this guy kind of liked
me
yeah you gotta have chemistry yeah with
your coach but he was cool i mean i
honestly like to he was like the only
one i could make the morning class but
uh he was cool so it was a scheduled
default thing that it's all about just
showing up guys just show up you know
that he lost like that fight that they
all went to
yeah and they still hired him as their
coach
and then i lost my fight but it's like
you know
i'm like oh and eight in the fights this
past two years
as far as coaching wise you know and the
one time our guy won we didn't even show
up no that's not good yeah that's not
true at one oh yeah that'll so we don't
count yeah he's a comedian i don't count
bro
pat's our buddy that [ __ ] chris sosa
who's also been on the show yeah yeah
that was crazy you know chris sosa yeah
yeah i met him so he actually has been
boxing since he was a kid because his
dad's a boxing coach
and his dad faked his death too that's
great and the story is so crazy yeah
what yeah bro we did a jk news about it
so basically a quick snippet is
chris sosa's dad
uh his wife was like nuts or some [ __ ]
and then he faked his death she was
trying to kill him she hired a
hit man from the gym though she hired
like a guy in the gym that he owns i'm
gonna hire anthony to kill alex
yeah what a rookie mistake he worked
with the cops like he faked his death
took pictures and then all that [ __ ] and
got her the pictures are low-key so bad
too did you see him they look so bad
like catch up and [ __ ]
she believe this [ __ ] that's how dumb
she is oh yeah he told the cops he
ratted he ran into the cops that he was
he was about to get hit by his own uh
wife and this dude in the gym so then
they faked his death in order to seem
like the hit happens yeah they could
what arrest her arrest her get her get
more information she actually paid the
people so once she paid them they were
able to arrest her yeah oh so okay i
understand now and the gym was the guy
in the gym was in on it so like because
he was friends with uh sosa's dad so
they kind of all set it up from there
tucci ass
but then in another crazy story
sosa and his boy pat did they did like a
comedian's only boxing event yeah that
sounds hilarious it's just crazy too how
did that even come about
i have no idea our homie uh jose raymond
really funny comedian
he's really dope he put it all together
he's a [ __ ] wild man all he wants to
do is box and he was like oh it should
be a good idea jokes and boxing yeah to
get all these random uh guys he does
shows with to just start fighting each
other most of them didn't know how to
box at all and they learned how to box
within like a month they look crazy yeah
it was just it was a total [ __ ] show a
lot of it was just swinging they were 10
seconds and
dude
yeah honestly and then one of the guys
there's this guy named jamar neighbors
who boxes like pretty regularly he's a
pretty funny comedian and he's jacked as
[ __ ] bro like he's dragging the [ __ ] out
he beat the [ __ ] out of this poor like
the hispanic guy
he's all out of shape and [ __ ] another
comedian i mean they just beat the shot
at each other why would they pair them
up that's [ __ ] like i don't know
maybe maybe that's the comedy part of it
that's the punch line huh but
but but that was the name of the show
that i didn't get credit for oh yeah
yeah yeah yeah so patrick and uh chris
were the only guys that actually had
boxing experience so they paired them
together and they fought
yeah and it was it was a fun little
match but yeah that's how we all know
each other we all train together and
then you know with alex and joe and bart
and david we all get together and we all
train so did you guys call it earlier we
don't train we like hang train hang
tight tell us about how david hangs and
trains with us so when i first when i
was training with nick it was always on
time we'd have like our hour sessions
and then
like day progression happening where
like he's like hey i want david to do
some partner drills come through i was
like all right cool so i got there for
the first session and david wasn't there
and then i was like all right cool
you were there to support him
and then so like the next time we go and
then he's like 30 minutes late then we
started doing classes and he was always
he would always be late but then it
would turn by how by how much would you
say like by the third class
i think the shortest time was like 25
minutes 25 minutes the first time i came
he was like yo show up it's going to be
at 10. i don't know how bart is i like
to be early so i'm like 9 40 or whatever
and i'm not wearing i'm like yo
he's already working out at the gym
before i like how come no one's here and
he's like oh don't worry i'm gonna be
there at like 10 30 and i'm like well i
thought you said everyone's playing show
up at 10. no no i'm just down the street
i'm all right
but that's the worst part he did live
down the street at the time and he was
always the latest he's the latest dude
he never shows up but he would come and
then like we'd get there and then we'd
all talk and then that 30 minutes late
turned into he comes in with something
to vent about already he comes in oh i
didn't sleep till five in the morning
yeah yeah yeah
his hair is kind of all messed up dave
is a [ __ ] mess bro yeah and then
we'll talk for like an hour and then
he'd be like you guys just want to go
eat
and then we just go eat instead
and then sometimes we'll be all right
let's get at least one round of mitts in
so we do like a one minute round of
minutes and then all right cool we
worked out enough let's go oh come on
i'm not cool enough what does that mean
like we hit we hit the mints you hit
each other's myths yeah okay this guy's
me you know like in the movies where
they're like oh yeah yeah we do that
[ __ ] yeah yeah that's stick [ __ ] i love
that and we do that for a minute that's
it 10 minutes or less a total of three
minutes because we each did one round
and then oh
i know and then the eating takes longer
than the training session all the time
i thought so that's why i can't do that
anymore that's how you guys i'll change
you guys that's fitness bro
show up chill for like an hour and a
half hit a minute for a minute and go
eat for like an hour and a half those
are good ratios that's what i'm telling
you is fun it is fun because every
friday we used to have like 10 people
right way more we'd have like it was
real and then there's a lot of people
you could train here i'm telling you
this is this is kendra's rehearsal
it's the same [ __ ] i think it's is it
you guys just hang dance hang on
we showed up like an hour late 40
minutes late and stuff how do you start
the choreo or start rehearsing if people
are they just catch up we'll get to work
when it's like the week of the show
but if you like start prepping like a
month before the show it's like
nothing happens it's crazy
the week of the show is when you guys
get going when we for real get going
like the week before it's like you think
you show up and everybody's trying to be
progressive and productive and stuff and
you like try to [ __ ] out ideas but then
you're like maybe we can like get more
creative if we like go eat
[Laughter]
we should talk about our costume style
yeah you want to hit the the restaurant
and then the best is while you're eating
you're like oh yeah this helps so much
i'm really you know i'm able to think
about more you want to go sleep
then the second the second somebody's
like uh you want to get a drink i'll get
one drink and then it's over
so i remember the first time i worked
out with bart because i knew him and
david were boys so i was like all right
it's kind of good probably gonna be like
david's situation got there at 70. he's
all right here let's start warming up
i'm like damn bro can i chill for a
second
and we do the whole workout i'm all
tired ron came and then he's an eyelash
train i'm like oh damn i'm kind of tired
though [ __ ]
that's why david never trains with bart
i know [ __ ] no i did a barbell video and
he's like can you do 5 30. i'm like no i
could do 5 30 in the [ __ ] morning
were you an [ __ ] from that's so good
he bought me like two months in advance
that's way too early bro and he's there
at five
it was like five in the morning in costa
rican time this cat's texting me about
two months from now can you come i'm
like
you got your time zones all [ __ ] up
dude so i think it's time for anthony to
make us crossover to start training with
us to do some dancing i can hear this
for a minute right now
we still got time hey anthony in between
takes he likes to do like a little
10-second lesson with me where you just
kind of do i'm just hey don't tell
people man i'm just trying to learn the
basics before i show up you know but
when you train with them though it's a
four or five hour commitment
four five hours but like one minute of
work right
you're interested about martial arts or
not yeah yeah i used to do martial arts
when i was younger and i really enjoyed
it did uh taekwondo
um and i even got like all the way to
like secondary black belt but i like
could never kick a fool's ass it was all
just like
it was all just like form forms suck bro
well that's why i got into choreography
that's what i'm saying i didn't learn
how to fight at all it's more mostly
dancing but it the kata's helped him be
a choreographer and a dancer and a kenja
but not a [ __ ] fight
can just look like warriors that they
don't fight yeah we're peace warriors
like the u.n i mean you'll scare people
until you start doing that [ __ ] right
before a fight they're like all right
never mind they know how to [ __ ] do
match line
and that's the thing about the kinjaz
like a lot of people really truly
believe that they're way better than the
jabberwockies yep across the board a lot
of people across the board how the [ __ ]
did we get here yeah i know right
today's video is brought to you by feels
cbd isn't about what you feel it's about
what you do not feel such as pain stress
anxiety that [ __ ] sucks i got a pretty
crazy combination of stress and anxiety
the other day
and it's from actually like what's going
on in afghanistan oh what so i started
feeling sad and [ __ ] yeah i actually
follow a bunch of um like veteran type
instagrams and stuff and like like news
like world news and i have a bunch of
vet buddies you know like one of our
closest buddies
he's been there and a lot of people
these days they just keep reposting
especially people have been there and uh
they feel like a lot of their work was
just you know useless they didn't do
anything so it kind of got to me and
then even though in my brain i'm like
well there's nothing we can do it's out
of our control you know it's just the
crazy thing that's happened but when i
was sleeping at night i'll think about
it and i'm like man this thing's
penetrating my dreams and so i'm not
getting well rested so the night after i
took some and helped me relax a little
bit i'm like okay cool so now my heart
and my body kind of match my brain which
i know i can't do much about it we just
got to let it play out and it actually
was able to get me some restful sleep
the next day i think cbd is a great way
to kind of balance out everything and
have like an unwinding
ritual before you go to sleep you just
get a few drops feels as easy to use you
can go
and then you put it on your tongue and
you go sleepy sleep without you know
maybe letting that mind turn into a
roller coaster and if you are
intimidated this is your first time you
don't know what to do there is an
awesome little hotline you can call
they'll help you through the process and
explain what might be kind of good for
you as a first timer and if you join
their fields monthly membership you'll
save money on every single order and you
can cancel at any time
yeah so you can become a member today by
going to fields.com
off the record to get 50 off your first
order plus free shipping that's f e a l
s dot com slash off the record o f f t h
e r e c o r d to get 50 off your order
plus free shipping thank you feels yeah
like you said pretty much
all right so back to like fight training
and david's shitty lack of time and
stuff
yeah [ __ ] david dude i had i had to quit
uh i had to choose one or the other like
because i was [ __ ] committing like
four hours hanging with these guys
because
in the morning i would actually start
with nick for an hour and we would train
and then we would wait for david to do
some kickboxing or whatever and then the
food would happen and then it would be
like by before i know it was i was
spending six hours with them and [ __ ] it
was the glory days man it was great that
was fun but yeah glory days well like
last week what was this
this is like what like this is before
pandemic yeah where we could train with
like 10-15 people and nobody would
wonder like hey where are you coming
from who are you hanging out oh yeah you
know nowadays you got to train at the
park or is there places no we don't
really we don't really have classes like
that i had like one session with this
dude during the pandemic at the park
yeah that was it or yeah and then i did
the other thing with at uh your buddy's
house the kickboxer's house oh yeah
that's right that's right yeah where are
you guys sessioning now not really
anywhere we have a garage that we go
dude jitsu at but that's pretty much
where we all go and train but we have i
haven't even trained with this guy in
years he hates me did the pandemic ruin
like a lot of like martial art gyms and
all that stuff that culture yeah a lot
of gyms closed down you know it's a lot
of touching in there you know yeah it's
exclusively touching close but what if
you're quarantined together and then you
train together that's what we kind of
did yesterday pandemic yeah like the
same group that trains is the same group
that you only hang out with yeah expose
yourself to other people that was pretty
much it because that's how we figured
out how to stay like in jk we didn't get
rona till like he's a buzzer bro
we did real good but you all did it
together yeah
i don't think we never got it no we
never got it we had a couple close calls
we had a couple close calls you did
because you almost came to bart's house
dude you should have i should have you
you would have gotten a party yeah
we were training with somebody and that
day he had covet yeah it was patrick
yeah we were training him first fight
let's put him on glass but i mean
but you guys didn't get sick after you
trained with them it was like two weeks
before like we all got it yeah he got it
for the same person
uh we have a source that we know where
we go where this guy got it from he was
looking for it and this guy is always on
these streets
bart's not ground zero nah he ain't
ground zone like victims here but it's
[ __ ] up the guy they don't have to say
who it is but i know who it is the guy
who gave him covet
like i i know the guy and i'm not you're
the one that introduced me to that i've
actually said his [ __ ] name dude
millions of people have covered it might
as well put somebody on blast here i'm
indirectly responsible for giving you
guys all kovitz oh you [ __ ] i'm
sorry you never even got it i didn't
even get it wait so this cat he's bart
was making out with him yeah he
introduced me to him we're making now he
doesn't make out them anymore yeah we
stopped making out and we're like doing
weekly makeout sessions he's he's in a
lot of trouble this guy so now we really
can't make out with this guy
hey i was already hearing about that
[ __ ] over at the shop yeah dude from
other people yeah so there's all these
you know there's guys make out with too
many dangerous dudes yeah we're we like
it you know you know i got it the
luckiest out of everyone so like um
when i got kovid i tested
no no no but check this though the
organic vaccine i got the antibody but i
wasn't contagious
when you check on the cdc now if your
symptoms are only uh no taste
and then uh like or stuffy nose but you
don't have a fever you don't have any of
those things you're not contagious that
was me that's dope yeah so you didn't
have a fever it was the chillest time
ever the chillest time my first time
with kobe it sucked balls though yeah
like yeah more than once i had it i had
it like at the beginning beginning
beginning before before everyone even
knew
he's probably the safest one in this
whole room yeah [ __ ] yeah dude i don't
go anywhere bro but then yeah i got it
real bad and it was like nuts i was like
[ __ ] this is crazy so then my second
time my body's used to it already maybe
i had it too because i had something
crazy in february man it was like some
bronchitis that i never felt before and
i was like i didn't sleep for three days
because i coughed so hard and mine was
december before your february yeah so
yeah covered man
anthony you dodged it so far
but
this room is a festering petri dish of
[ __ ] something so yeah
whatever i mean it's just a matter of
time everyone's gonna get it why you
guys say like that all a matter of time
like that that's how science works
if we do shots then it it cleans up
the macrobiomes really that's what helps
that's why i've been drinking every day
because i'm trying to keep it you know
the doctor away alcohol kills all the
germs because i use alcohol to you know
wet the site where you inject anyways
there you go what do you inject yeah he
puts vodka on it yeah what do you want
to inject a little bit of you know
testosterone how come you don't want to
do steroids why are you such a [ __ ]
about it how come you don't want to do
steroids hey it's fun is it dick stuff
you talk about steroids he's done it
before you know steroids you [ __ ]
don't look like stuff
you're [ __ ] the biggest dude in the
room dude come on bro tell me bart is
probably just as wide as me no no bro
you you have you touch this guy joe just
as wide as me this guy feels like the
outside of a house me
like he doesn't feel like a human being
you know we stuck in the mountains like
i'm gonna i'm gonna eat you first
small dude if we had to eat alex where
would you guys actually i might eat
steve first like
wait what the [ __ ] well you got the
disease stuff so you're probably going
first anyway you know somebody's
diseased one
[ __ ] multi-covet thing you know we
got to like eat your antibodies steve
drinks a lot he's probably like kobe
beef he's like he's probably way softer
i'm really relaxed i'm really relaxed
he's wagging dude probably take a bite
of stephen on a caffeine higher right
caffeine ingrained in his meat baby yeah
but then we're going to get to the roids
yeah no really you don't rush before i'm
hella cute look at me i'm hella skinny i
took tests for about eight months what's
that testosterone testosterone how's
your day it's good honestly it didn't
the thing with like steroids is it
shrinks your balls did your balls drink
because i had some buddies where like oh
sure my balls go yeah my balls gotta
they didn't like cosmetic anywhere
though yeah he cares about the balls but
they they were like they got a little
smaller but when you're done they kind
of go back to normal
when you're [ __ ] is it like less come
or
dude very important questions not some
people no i i've always thought like
people get off gear when they're trying
to have a kid and it just because
they're you become if you take enough
you become sterile so like you have less
semen so i'm like yeah it kills your
sperm count so when you're [ __ ] is it
like just jello or some [ __ ] or like
powder uh nah
but to ash i want to say i didn't really
see a big difference in that and that
type of stuff i think it doesn't like
jello jigglers or nothing
because i did like a i did a smaller
amount supposedly so people i was doing
like 600 a week
i guess some people do start with 900
and stuff like that so i was doing two
injections a week one on tuesday one on
saturday so you talking about milligrams
yeah and then when you say injections
like how does i don't know [ __ ] about
steroids how does that [ __ ] work like
what do you have like a heroin needle
this was that was the worst part that's
why i stopped because i hated it because
like i was so nervou i had seen videos
of people getting like infections and
[ __ ] like that so it made me so nervous
so yeah you get the alcohol pad you'd
wipe your shoulder or wherever you're
gonna do it so i would use literally
like 20 alcohol pads use one let it dry
do one let it dry do one the but i don't
have the mobility for that sort of reach
yeah it has to be intramuscular is that
why it has to be in your muscle i see so
like when you so like first you know you
guys want the whole step you get the you
get the little while turn it upside down
tell me how it goes
all right did you get the vinyl uh
illegally okay okay
in mexico
in mexico all these farmers we would get
the plug off camera
in mexico i got it from
the ice man
that's true that's true
um so you put it in you make sure
there's like no bubbles right oh yeah
flick it yeah no so you put the syringe
in you press it all the way out to let
all the air then you pull it to how much
you want
you take it out and then if there's like
a little bubbles or whatever you push it
out a little bit so there's like no air
it's like regular drugs okay exactly you
do the whole thing
you dry it you clean it off whatever
like that and then i remember i think it
was like from your muscle your bone
right here on your shoulders like three
fingers under it's like under the bone
the shoulder blade behind the bone
muscle like the main muscles that yeah
so you put it in you you like pull it
out a little bit because the whole thing
is if you pull it out and there's blood
that means you like hit a vein so you
don't want to put it directly like in
your bloodstream so like if you do that
you have to take it out and put it
somewhere what happens if it goes in
your bloodstream i don't know i never
did that but you'll it's not it's not
good i think it's yeah i think you don't
want that to happen yeah so then i did
it too much power once you once you pull
it out and it's like it's weird because
it's like really hard like to pull it
out because there's like your muscles
wrap around air there's no nothing right
so like you feel it no blood comes out
then you press it in and you think it's
going to be like
it's literally you're having to use two
fingers like
can you feel it uh filling up your
shoulder not really no um and after you
inject when do you
feel it or is it or what do you feel
yeah what do you feel nothing
no you just you inject it in like the
next day it might be like a little like
tender sore like that but i'd say it
took about like two weeks for it to kick
in then how do you know it's working you
have a big ass bicep all of a sudden
well the whole thing is like no no road
rage i didn't get roid rage i wish but
the like after about two weeks it's like
i would work out and i'm like damn i'm
not sore and like i would have so much
energy and like i was telling bart i
would bench three times a week and i was
never sore and i was like damn this
feels good i would deadlift twice a week
i was never sore i squat i only squat
once but i was never sore so i was like
testosterone helps you with soreness
with recovery recovery so that's that's
the biggest like i guess um
uh like misconception about steroids is
they think you inject and then you go
boosh it's not really the case what the
case is you inject and because you're so
able to recover you can handle insane
amounts of workload
and then so now and you're more anabolic
so now that you have this much amount of
workload where like before you could
only run maybe five miles a week now you
could run like five miles morning lunch
and dinner then now your your body just
starts adapting to the stimulus that you
apply to it but that sucks i just want
to inject it and be done with it i don't
even want to work out
there was a study it is more anabolic so
you will grow a little bit more muscle
there was a study where like they had
they did a study of like five people
that did nothing and then five people
that did nothing but took tests and they
still gained about like six pounds of
muscle holy [ __ ] there you go but it was
nice that was all though my whole thing
was i stopped because i just hated doing
the the needle
if it was a pill would you do it again
no that that one's even scarier to me
yeah hard on your liver and stuff like
if there was no side effects would you
do it oh yeah 100 i'd still do it right
now there was no
[ __ ] yeah man
um but it was fun like i wouldn't mind
doing it again it's just like i don't
have like a reason to do it i heard that
like when you get off of it then your
body's like oh [ __ ] where'd a test go
and then it kind of freaks out i've
heard stories about i had a pretty good
uh cycle good cycle you got to come off
the correct way or something right yeah
i don't i don't even think i did though
like people were telling me about like
you have to take this type these types
of things to get off i kind of just i
was doing 600 a week
and then i switched it to uh
uh 600 every two weeks so i'll do 300
300
once a week once a week and then i
switched to 300 every other week and
then i just stopped taking it and i felt
fine so you did kind of like
yeah i just tapered off like
people tell me like oh you need to take
this this this i was like i just slowly
got up why is just why is it illegal is
it like prescription
pills yeah dude can't have a bunch of
hotties walking around like don't do
this by itself it's too sexy
that's what i want i want to start the
way you do this and then just because
it's illegal right yeah i'll do that one
you will grow more hair yeah hey my back
started getting a little hairy i knew
that because my barber started like
shaving down here i'm like boy what you
doing when he gave you the fade he
started with the lower back
he's sticking the clippers in the back
of your shirt you're like yo what the
[ __ ] you doing in there like this on my
bro what are you doing
why is it illegal though because it just
i don't know is does it is it like a
doctor has to help you through it or
whatever yeah i mean they do prescribe
it to people like older people i think
your test number has to be under 400 and
then we'll start giving it to you or
something even lower probably lower but
i don't know i think people should be
able to like why not who gives a [ __ ]
you can drop you can drink you can do
all this [ __ ] this whole roid rage thing
i think is a little like overplayed too
yeah steroids will like whoever you are
it will just amplify it so like if
you're super nice you're just gonna be
nice when you're on it look in that
camera right there and say hey kids do
steroids do steroids
make sure you clean your your shoulders
those alcohol pads
good messages
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you